luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel me and my family we're
snorkeling and spearfishing the entire
uk england wales
scotland
and northern ireland
[Music]
how you doing nice to meet you nice to
meet you
i've got max here with the frenchman
spearfishing course and i've got harvey
here with the youtube channel spearfin
and we've got john and sam we're gonna
be helping make sure that i don't drown
myself too yeah yeah let's go poke a
fish
i gotta tell you what folks this is a
different way to see england
look at that you just found that right
there you tasted control i've never had
them raw
yeah it's a nice one
oh thank you
they're sweet and salty
yeah
that is really good moment of truth time
to jump in
[Music]
yeah there's like this old abandoned
crab trap in there they're just full of
the crabs
caught a few crabs ate a scallop
we're off to roaring start
little signal there
uh
well there's carnival down there huh
all right we're gonna try something a
little different we're gonna dive and
see if we can't find some lobsters
so
hahaha
this
oh
[Music]
yeah
i don't mean to brag harvey but i'm kind
of the spider crab king now
i don't make the rules
i think i have enough use of my fingers
now i can fillet the fish
there we go
a couple pulley fillets if you want to
check out a youtube channel if somebody
actually knows what they're doing check
out harvey's youtube channel spearfin
and i'll put a link in the video
description below and if you guys want
to come over here and do this too make
sure to check out max's charter business
got a bag of spider crabs and some fresh
pulley it's time to head back home i'm
going to turn the heater way up
is that warm and fuzzy
what do you think
[Music]
if i want to play
look at that big chunk of meat these are
like king crab bodies with little snow
crab legs on them but they're still
there's loads of meat on these
ah i'll tell you what that crab was
delicious but i am exhausted i am gonna
go upstairs to take the longest hot
shower i can
and i'll see you guys in the morning
we're in milford haven in southwest
wales
and i'm here with dave george and
richard with pembrokeshire boat charters
and we are gonna go poke a fish and i'm
really excited because the weather's
actually really nice today
there we go just driving through the
locks getting out of the harbor
a little seal right over there
well there's plenty of spider crabs
oh
[Music]
little baby fish chips
try to look graceful
ready well check it out david here is
cooking up some lunch
wealth cake huh yeah well it looks like
a little squished scone a little bit
well guys i'm full of bacon sandwiches
and wonderful welsh cakes here and we're
gonna go try another little spot and see
if we can't find a sea bass
[Music]
awesome gorgeous scenery a ton of spider
crabs and loads of pulling
well dave tells me there's an island
with some puffins on it we're gonna go
check that out before heading back in
you can see all these little puffin
burrows up at the top of the cliff
there's these big black back seagulls
and they're swooping down and eating
puffins oh yeah yeah
they seem remarkably chill about the
fact that they're just getting picked
off one by one but we're running out of
time so we're gonna head back to the
marina and
i'm proud to say that i'm not freezing
[Music]
if you guys are in southern wales and
you would like to do a spear fishing
trip like this or any sort of boat
charter trip check out pembrokeshire
boatcharters.co.uk i'll put a link in
the video description below all right
hey guys thank you very much
your destination is on the left
well we're back home and i am going to
make some fish curry
[Music]
um
so what do you guys think of the curry
good oh it's good
i speared it for you it's the end of a
wonderful day and i'm sitting here with
a hot water bottle under my shirt and i
will see you guys in the morning we got
more awesome stuff to do tomorrow
the no seems got in the car i freaked
out
[Music]
all right guys
we are going out with basking sharks
scotland dot co dot uk and we couldn't
ask for a more gorgeous perfect day look
at this
get through the big poop party
there's some dolphins right by the boat
oh right there yeah there's a whole
bunch of them right over there
there's probably 20 or so at least that
we see
there you go oh yeah you can see him
rebecca is this cool
oh look they're coming
up
that was cool
check it out guys it's fingal's cave
it's the end of the giant's causeway
it's a rock formation that starts in
northern ireland goes under the ocean
and ends here in the islands of scotland
we're gonna get to swim inside it
look at these cool rock formations now
this is twinkle's cave the whole island
is the isle of stapa
pretty cool
look at all of the roof here
you got one all right
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
oh what do you think babe that's amazing
i'm so glad we did that
i think it's like a seaweed like oh yeah
yeah guys
there's plants coming out of my face
well that's spingles cave now we're
gonna go to another spot where there's a
little bit calmer so we might be able to
get the boys in the water i am a lot
warmer than i was down in cornwall i'll
tell you a nice sunny beautiful day
makes all the difference
oh look at that water jake look we got
yours
you look like a medieval peasant there
oh look at those cute little cheeks it's
just so squishy
[Music]
jake just abandoned me
[Laughter]
there we go
[Music]
foreign
there's a seal over there isn't that
cool yeah
[Music]
hey tommy do i do it in yeah was it cold
yes what was the coolest thing you saw
probably the seals
you got all three of them you're brave
just take time to work
i see the egg
penguins they're gilly mucks
[Music]
oh
you got your hot water bottles
i got two
is that fun yeah
listen if you're ever in urban scotland
and you'd like to snorkel with basking
sharks or swim with seals or go to
phoenix cave or do any of the stuff you
saw us do check out
baskingsharksscotland.co.uk i'll put a
link in the video description below to
their website are you guys tired
oh i am so tired
it's brown
lots of brown good morning guys it is a
beautiful day
i think i need to go diving
[Music]
so
guys we have had an absolutely wonderful
time and we've actually been here in the
uk for about five weeks and we've done a
whole lot more than just snorkeling and
spear fishing we're actually taking all
of that footage and putting it into one
big video and i'm gonna post that video
and put a link in the video description
below so thanks for watching guys i hope
you enjoy this and if you want to see
more videos like this make sure to check
out our playlist and click subscribe to
the outdoor boys youtube channel thanks
for watching guys
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching